get ready for more Eddie opposed to
sprung up on reddit from a user in
Russia who claims have seen elites
trailer for the upcoming venom two well
we haven't gotten a glimpse of it
stateside yet the reddit sir hopefully
provided a full breakdown for us to chew
on well it seems like pretty much every
20/20 phone release has been pushed back
to the full in the wake of the ongoing
covert 19 outbreak it looks like venom 2
will benefit from already having been
slated for release in that frame the
flick is jus in theaters on October 2nd
and so far that release date has held
firm fans off 2018 s venom were floored
when in the flicks post-credits sequence
they were introduced to a very dangerous
inmate with whom Eddie Brock has lined
up an interview cletus kasady a brutal
serial killer who was destined to become
the insanely dangerous symbiotic villain
carnage hi Eddie
hey you mind if we forego the whole
creepy serial killer thing here
according to our Russian reddit sir the
trailer for venom 2 will give us our
first fleeting look at Cassidy in
full-on carnage mode while also teasing
the plot device which puts the murderer
on a collision course with our favorite
tungee antihero of course we must say
before we go any further that this leak
is in no way confirmed and it may just
be the product of one venom fans fertile
imagination or so the events of the
trailer and a style ugh have been
translated to English from Russian with
an online translator so we're basically
just going to have to run down the
synopsis as best we can
with the information we have having said
all that the leak sounds pretty legit
and it also sounds like venom 2 is going
to be pretty freakin awesome
according to the reddit post the trailer
opens with a shot of San Francisco as a
voice overlords venom as a new protector
of the city have you gone anywhere in
the city preying on innocent people and
we will find you
through arms and the both of your legs
we then see a group of children
trick-or-treating but they've come to
the wrong house the door is answered by
Cassidy who removes his Halloween mask
to reveal that his face is starting to
well carnage else he then laughs and the
trailer cuts away
we then see Cassidy pursuing Brock in a
car chase with police on both their
tails then Brock is seen checking out a
newspaper clipping about an orphanage
burning down there's then a bit of
conversation between Brock and the Venom
symbiote with Brock indicating something
to the effect that carnage is just
getting started again the translation
here isn't great then there's a scene of
prog transforming and venom scaling the
outside of a church where Cassidy is
holed up a spot fades to black and
carnage is herded voice over saying that
his goal is more than just well 110
carnage before cutting the black the
trailer ends with a brief scene of a cop
shooting at Cassidy who stops the bullet
with an alley tentacle and then the cop
screaming in terror as Cassidy begins to
transform again even though the leak is
far from confirmed and the translation
is rough we're cautiously optimistic
that our Russian redditor did indeed
catch a sneak peek of the venom 2
trailer the description above a follows
all the typical beats of a standard
superhero movie teaser trailer and B is
pretty much exactly what we would expect
teasing the confrontation between venom
and carnage without giving away too much
of the movies plus of course we should
know for certain whether or not the
sleekest legit sooner rather than later
like we mentioned venom 2 is still
holding fast to his October release date
and assuming that there are no setbacks
between now and then not only gives Sony
about five months to promote the flick
dropping a teaser trailer sooner rather
than later would be a pretty good way to
get fans totally psyched thought might
be one of their first chances to catch a
major movie in the theater post covert
quarantine and since venom cleared 850
million dollars of the worldwide box
office the sequels certainly qualifies
as major you know us will be keeping an
eye out for any official word on the
leak or better yet an actual trailer
drop as soon as we have either we'll be
beating down your door with the news now
get out
here and I will there's gonna be carnage
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos buy
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]